but for instance or when I go with this
maybe again when we go to their actual
demos and examples so let's let's go
let's go what we gonna do today so let
me introduce myself my name is Paulo
Paul Pataki or if you speak an Eastern
European language is Pavel pototsky
depends now I work for JP Morgan
commodities EMM technology team bata
relation I've been doing for for many
years in late 1990s and early 2000s
actually JP Morgan and working with
specialized data preservation group that
was called data visualization group and
we did a lot of C++ and Java stuff for
different desks and right now I'm using
Python for some a lot of my work and
data possession it's really always been
always important part of my work in
different aspects of it in different
ways I can bring the applications to the
users working business environment it's
always a little bit different because
you have the needs of others that you
have to subscribe to so later ization is
part of what which or what people like
sales and business tries to look at the
different types of data and analyze it
so the devastation is always a big part
of it so what we're going to talk about
here so a quick overview of what so so
this this is basically I have a few
slides and examples I'm gonna not be
mixing matching those two so a little
bit is a overview of the visualization
some UI toolkits
so this is for those who expected some
sort of notebook to put a notebook this
is not like that because we're talking
about interactive standalone
applications so we need different
approach to it so I have a standalone
files that you can run as applications
you know I explained it in amo because
in amo it's the tool that binds all this
visualization for me when I'm building
those
and I explained it but what's vtk das
matplotlib and put this all together how
do I interact with this so now this is
not in-depth tutorial about mouth but
lip that was something else that was
yesterday was good one there's not in
the tutorial about enamel or vtk but
it's I'm just gonna we have just a lot
of certain amount of times I have to
kind of glance through it just show you
what's possible so then you can go and
explore on your own this is the
screenshots ones of VT key visualization
and most of the examples here are China
trying to bring any data that I have at
work or whatever it's just the stock
examples people work in a bank
understand that you can't really do that
so here let's go so why building
visualization interactive visualization
so this is something that I know there's
a big effort now out there for web
applications are the great things like
bouquet that uses html5 canvas that can
do 2d and 3d rendering with WebGL people
use Jupiter notebooks ipython rides if
you do this type of things but this is
more like I would say in academia it's a
great thing you can create the notebook
with all that visualization you can
share with your friends are the
colleagues with different universities
and so forth in business I can see the
quants using that let's say you do some
modeling and then just sharing across
their their group different groups but
in many cases in business you really
have to build standalone GUI standalone
applications and the effort always to
build either long-term applications and
then you can build for six months one
year complex UI so you can build like a
simpler tools that you want to deliver
to the particular desk it's anybody work
on a trading floor it understands that
there is a need of quickly creating some
applications that certain people can use
at certain time they have an ability to
maybe slice and dice data they don't
really need a huge effort you don't need
to put a huge effort to it brain to put
this together quickly and you cannot
have to deliver it so there is always
very strong need of interactive
standalone applications there is this
always
throughout my career I there is always
there is a switch between thin clients
the thick clients the thin clients the
thick lines so this back and forth the
know the UNAM oh I'm gonna talk about it
considers me so that's a thick client
the thin client doesn't really matter I
mean it's a great tool to create those
quick you eyes
so we need to in business environment
create those quickly and high-quality
obviously and and something that people
can use we can we don't really need to
spend one year of developing some of
your eyes I mean it's just a couple
weeks couple days so we need the tools
to put this all together so this is the
spiel about Python I'm gonna quickly go
over this because all the Python
developers here so we don't have to
really explain anything to it what I
want to say is that Python really
exploded probably last few years I mean
especially in business I see it coming
in in big waves there is a couple of
good packages and the the big really big
strength of the Python is that it binds
very well with the other framework so we
can use C++ framework for really doing
some intensive visualization or
processing and Python allows us to
quickly just glue this and put this
together and access this very quick way
in UI world
there's several UI toolkits let me just
switch to that I should probably mention
here okay there's a several toolkits out
there that very well live with Python
one of them is WX so it's kind of older
but still in being developed UI toolkit
that has a Python binding called WX
Python and there is a QT which is little
bit newer
came from Nokia it's open-source and I
think it's a little bit better it's new
where has some very powerful features
and
the night's so-so probably would the
only drawback with this UI toolkits like
the Qt and WX is that the fact that they
are multi-platform so they tend to be
big and heavy because they have to
address Linux you are Native bridges
they have to address the Mac OS or
Windows so they tend to be heavy but you
always want to use the good thing is
that you develop the code that runs
everywhere so your Python runs
everywhere your duty bindings run
everywhere so you write the code that
runs on Windows and UNIX and Linux and
because you just use the subset of the
runtime libraries anyway at the time so
the speed is good the size of
installation might be a little bit big
so I really like qt we've been using QT
for a while over the WX we started with
W eggs but we switched to Qt has a
little nicer interfaces and has some
nice features like slots and signals and
also QT offers something interesting
with Q ml which is declarative language
which allows you to declare your
applications in a simple file and then
just run this and this binds dear
widgets for you so if I switch and now
all so I discover number few years ago I
was working with the primary router oven
ammo was from continuing named Chris
Kolbert and in our kindness influence
but QM else it's also declarative
language so allows you to quickly create
your declaration you rewrite
declarations and it's at this moment
it's in a sense only extension of QT so
instead of let's say working in QT you
can work with a novel and you know that
you're gonna have a QT which is
underneath and access to most of them
the nice thing about the cute enamel
versus q ml is the anomalous pythonic
it's just it's Python it's a Python
extensions so when you run the code
actually gets compared to Python byte
code so you can also
debug the same as
item so you can put your breakpoints
there and there's always a problem when
the URI development when you have some
sort of distributed separated system
that maybe your visualization I mean the
UI declarations are in some sort of file
and then your controllers are somewhere
else then how you put the breakpoints
how you're gonna do bag this so nice
thing about the Maya is all Python it's
there's no additional language involved
no national bindings you know it's it's
Python I mean underneath there are some
C++ widgets obviously but in a sense you
work with Python so you you can work
with the title as Python object you can
extend it you can overload it you can
overwrite things you can put the
breakpoints and it's it's really very
very powerful language I initially I was
a little skeptical about it or it came
from the world when you kind of declare
everything in a in a program yourself
but this allows you to kind of declare
separate your views so runs if you
familiar with Model View controller this
one actually runs very nicely with that
meaning you declare your views in a
novel now we're gonna show some examples
in a few minutes so this is some snippet
I don't think anybody can see it but
we'll go to their code and and has some
very powerful futures like dynamics
copying like layout management like
binding with the Akamai objects which
I'm going to explain what it is so it's
really very friendly it's easy to learn
and and very powerful you can create the
dynamic applications so they're the
certain parts of the UI can be
dynamically created based on some sort
of action so it's it's easier than just
maybe programming this you know you know
in a cutie per set right so maybe I
should bring some simple a normal file
just to show
I should have PyCharm here so that can I
make this bigger
sorry I think I don't think I can make
this much bigger
I think this is like the simplest
example here actually let's go to animal
examples you say this animal examples
are part of the animal distribution so
it's just easy to I don't know if you
can see but basically this is here and
I'm all or maybe just make it even
simpler it's probably the simplest one
you can have so basically you declare
your UI here you declare and you declare
main functions so now all has something
called animal dev that's the llama has
like I said it's Python but it has its
own keywords and attributes to make it a
little bit different right so so animal
day if it's like your definition
equivalent death for for Python function
definition and you have attributes and
then basically what you do here you just
lay out your tool your UI with declare
your your component so in this case we
have just a couple of components we have
a main window we have a some sort of
message which is an attribute which can
always manipulate will show that later
and then we have a little container
which think of it like you some sort of
box inside that container there is
something called label which it's you
know just a text and just a message
that's it so very simple nothing to it
okay so we're gonna go a little bit more
into details later
it's any questions of our
yeah oh good good
good question Mike actually wanted to go
to so there is a two ways to run it let
me actually show you so you run it there
is a with anaconda there is a there is a
command distributed with animals called
animal run so I know if you can buddy
can see it on the ballots and now I
don't know how to make this bigger I
maybe if I can make this terminal bigger
when was the font
to make this bigger anyway so this is a
command it's called a normal run and
then basically you run you a normal file
so and I'm gonna - run space so this is
reka wrapper that provides that's
provided the UNAM Oh provides for you to
run the enamel files and then that
assumes that you have that main fire in
it and I would just execute that main so
if I run this this article demo I want
to talk about a little bit later that's
when I was actually creating some
date/time components so I'll show that
in a second but basically that's it
right and there is also a and another
thing most of the examples that I have
actually I run it from the code from
pycharm that are there is you can
bootstrap Dena more I'll show you how to
do it but basically you can either
animal run or you can do the
bootstrapping in your code and what I'm
gonna do actually I'm gonna run another
example file which I'm gonna use it
that github that I showed you
yes everything is there oh let me go
back yes
oh no no no the enamel examples are part
of enamel distribution so you can also
get it from github okay so now the only
tutorial the examples our interests are
you go to you go to github tool and you
can look for an arm or you search Google
it's very easy and then you grab this
whole distribution and there's an
examples folder and you can run through
them it's a whole bunch of them what I
want to do here is I want to run this
editor here which is very useful I want
to show it you know so it's a normal run
and then I have something called life
I want to bring it up because I want to
talk about this as well
okay so basically simple and I'm around
now let me just switch here just to kind
of continue my thought and I would go
back to those things now in our vs. qml
so like if somebody wants to wrestle
what do I want to use they want to use
animal kill now
this is a snippet from qml bio is also
very similar like you see it hosts a key
window it has some menus bars buttons is
very similar to an hour it follows the
JSON syntax and but the problem with
this is that it's not pythonic meaning
you you run that in the Qt environment
and there's a JavaScript engine behind
it that interprets this renders allows
you to render widgets so it's it's a
little bit it obviously comes from q QT
so you can say well it's it's a big
effort behind it but it's not really
Python I I don't think that's it's like
if you're Python developer and
everything you're working with Python
then you're just really definitely want
to have an enamel the nice thing about
the KML is because it comes with a QT
its supports all the widgets that they
have everything out of the box and our
builds building is building up the
widget set so there's a huge number of
widgets right now most important ones
that you can create the visualization or
you I swear it's like buttons and
layouts and stuff like that but doesn't
have everything and sometimes there's
things that maybe you wanna tweak it a
little bit I found myself going into a
little bit deeper level into enamel to
maybe get handle of their actual QT
widgets from the enamel and they maybe
just modify it if I wanted to but all
that should be gone because that should
actually I should talk to developers on
enamel and just that should be probably
exposed at some point so it's growing
maybe it's not going very fast but I
hope it's gonna go faster that's why I'm
giving this talk and once the bigger
community builds around it then
definitely we can you know maybe request
more support from from widgets in enamel
but as a programmer as a lighting
developer you really want to stick with
an
it's very easy it's decorative like qml
but it's enamel so you can put the
breakpoint I can actually show that in a
second and so forth and I'm offering so
again if you go through an amo if you
google what do an AMA website you find
there is a some sort of documentation
there there is a whole bunch of widgets
that they support out of the box of the
QT the most important one like labels
combo boxes date selectors pop up views
buttons label suffered one of the beauty
great thing for creating the
visualizations and you UI's its docking
layouts which I'm going to show later
and one of the important thing for me
was really ok I can use an ammo it's
fine but I really need to make sure that
I can create dynamic interfaces now if I
press some buttons and some action
happens I want to pop up some interface
that can be built dynamically for me and
that can be done with the things like
include like looper like condition so
this additional feature is built in an
enamel that allows you to do that
there's also style sheets and templates
I'm not going to talk about that this is
something that you can then use to spice
it up your views there's also some timer
deferred codes which are much we talk
about timer I have a timer example and
so it's it's a rich offering allows you
to really build the rich use UI out of
the box right so maybe what I should do
is before I switch part or maybe run
some examples and I maybe come back to
it as well
so for instance here if you go to pie
chart I have a couple of examples here
let me just show you how to bootstrap
this in a code so
let me just find like a simple example
let's say
yeah
so I know if you can see but basically
it's just a couple of lines of code to
bootstrap your enamel applications so
you import and now more than from Qt
plan QT applications because that which
you need for the main UI thread main UI
thread and then the trick is because so
the trick with enamel is that because
it's a pythonic it's Python but it has a
normal extension most of the UI ite they
don't it doesn't they don't understand
the enamel work what's anomalous so
somehow like you need to make it tweak
it maybe I use pycharm so you can
actually add the color syntax saying or
pydev in eclipse or IntelliJ but it
still doesn't understand it so sometimes
you get all these errors but you need to
have that because animal it's separate
fire in a sense so you do need to do
this with animal import so you need to
import your object your class whatever
from animal with this with animal import
so then you can use it in your Python
code so I have some examples here and
I'm going to just comment this going out
and uncomment this going out and then it
is basically create the application and
call your main function so I mean
putting the main function so which one
is that
unplug demo dynamic and plot them dino
here so i'll go a little bit more
details later how what i do here right i
just want to run it just want to show
you that i've built this UI here so this
is my main method here that i'm calling
that extends the window so i want to
have a window to start this with and
then i have some sort of container which
is the box in which I'm gonna put some
components in this case I have a mat mat
plot container which contains the mat
plot and you know canvas and then you
have a couple of buttons and
stuff like that so I'm gonna run this
I think that's gonna go underneath
somewhere
so this is sort of matplotlib
embedded in a novel right so I'll go a
little bit later on what details what
I'm doing here you know I can refresh
this data set I can have the toolbar so
this is the toolbar that comes with an
hour I mean with the matplotlib you can
kind of access this this uses the Qt
backend so as you know from other talks
and MATLAB Plutarch's they have several
backends here we're using QT backends
you can just change just just couple of
just change the location of that toolbar
you can just get rid of it there's some
config file which for which I use pop up
so this is another animal at widgets
called pop-up view and then I have some
slider some you know some stuff so I can
kind of play with it so the whole idea
for me to show you is the interactivity
of easy how to interact easily with
matplotlib or vtk with an hour so the
animal will allows me to build this you
eyes put these components all over the
place and then I can hook myself through
the different events which I'm going to
show you two underlying components like
canvas like this is the manipulating the
figure of matplotlib here right now so
so this is one of the demos and the code
and just kill it
they call it self it's maybe a little
bit at first overwhelming but it's very
simple it's just again I'm using this
this attributes I'm using the container
I'm going to go actually let me go and
simplify this talk a little bit and
so this is before I go to four so this
is what I wanted to show you here is
that vtk what sweetie carry so vtk is a
very powerful OpenGL based
object-oriented framework for
visualization it does really heavy-duty
visualization on surfaces of
three-dimensional for the measurement of
volumetric you can slice it dice it do
whatever you want at it it's it's really
powerful it's been around for twenty
years of these and it's been progressing
there's new releases all the time I was
mentioning this in the beginning of 6.3
just came out so it's really really
actively developed it's maybe a little
mesh meaning that it's really complex to
maybe use but with a normal we can maybe
make it easier so anomic first yeah I
was talking to Chris when he worked with
me at JP Morgan's some time to actually
include the zvtk canvas into the enamel
so this is enamel offers this vtk canvas
widget that basically takes your
rendering your rendering engine that
contains your rendering objects so I'll
show you how this works and you can then
find yourself through a novel tool at
any point of that visualization pipeline
to kind of change that so we have the
BTK we have a bit icky widget and
everything at the ABT case the c++
luncheon but has the Python bindings has
the Java binding has some other bindings
but because of the bindings it tight on
them it really makes it easier to
actually use with decay than you would
use to C++ because you kind of almost
interacted we can do your visualization
and change it and different aspect of it
unlike in C++ when you have to compile
you know maybe some box deploy and stuff
like that so Python actually makes it
very easy to actually go in kind of
stuff allows you to play with the
vehicle on a deeper level so this is the
vtk we're going to talk about and
another one is a map plot lab that has
been known for many years as well
there's a lot of talks about math live
everywhere you go it was a good one
yesterday
a huge amount of different type of plots
and charts is really overwhelming there
is a big use of it in notebooks like the
Jupiter notebook or but what I want to
show you is how to can actually embed it
in you know user interfaces use
applications GUI applications and for
that we also enamel provides widget for
it called MPL canvas and that because
anomalous QT base so therefore we're
using the QT back-end and if you
attended the talk you said about
matplotlib at some point there was a
mentioning this object-oriented way of
doing the matplotlib so therefore we
actually extracting here the object so
things like figure like access that then
we can manipulate through a now so show
this examples again and again just what
I was mentioning in the beginning all
this is a viable in anaconda just get it
accepted BTK you usually have to install
it separate but everything is there you
know so MATLAB for the mudblood
visualization here found us if you want
to get some data and numpy and now all
hopefully that's gonna get updated with
the examples that I have today at home
which I'm gonna mention again the animal
and Adam cannon live together and I'm
gonna actually can control your models
to Adam which I will explain in a second
and the qt4 version 4.8 I think at this
moment is in anaconda but I'm sure it's
updated everything gets updated along so
why animal is so powerful why is so good
and because offers this dynamic binding
switch a model you don't have to really
write a lot of code in order to modify
something it uses this atom object which
is optimized C++ back and base object
that you
declare certain art arguments in it
ahead of time so he knows how to compile
this properly in York you specified them
almost like a strict type so basically
if you have some sort of member you say
it's int or if I have some other it's
maybe string or something else so it
kind of allows you to kind of pre
compile this and optimize it for speed
but the most important thing is allows
you to this bi-directional connection
between your model and your UI so you
can have a UI that can manipulate your
model your visualization and on the
other hand you can change your model
visualization changes your model then
maybe some thread changes your model
that changes the visualization right so
this is backward and that's that so
anomaly and atom makes this powerful and
you can do the same thing with a q-tip
you know you can write this using
signals and slots but this one makes
much easier it means in many cases you
just want to just quickly do this UI
without just going deep into writing a
lot of code and again like I said before
it's it's because it's pythonic you just
can build your own libraries you know
and you can just add things to it that
they can you reduce your application so
one thing I'm going to do is I'm going
to show you a couple of examples for
instance here in this slide let's say I
wanted to create a new slider the slider
is kind of useful rather you want to
slide some data on you want to slice it
and dice it and in here you have slicer
control the slot the slider itself
I'll let me just bring this code it's
probably better
so I have something so in examples when
you download something called slider so
there is actually a slider component in
a novel but it just basically slider
with the I was just showing you the demo
actually here let me run this again so
the slider here that comes with enamel
it's that little slider little box
doesn't really have anything it has just
a little widget that you can slide now
you don't have any information that you
maybe add to it all right so it's it's
very simple but let's say I want to have
a little nicer I want the slider to be a
little bit deeper and have more
information right so let me run another
example and vtk which i think is
so let me
which ones that
I should I have this here Coliseum let
me just pour out this and I'll go back
let me around this example two windows
of you and Allah okay so this help
so this is my example and I'm gonna run
this so I'll show you now how do I maybe
want to have a nicer slider sorry that
actually does something else so I have
this vtk visualization here and see this
is the slider components that I've just
showed you in a code that it has a
little bit more so I want to have a
container that controls my labels I have
a minimum value of maximum value maybe I
wanna some values to show so I am
sending this slider with that piece of
code so now if I slice this if I go and
I can slice to the visualization here I
can actually see what's going on right
so so here the code for there is so let
me just kill this again basically
because it's behaves like Python I can
just write my control over right
container and inside this container I
can start stack my components which is
the slider then I want to stack some
labels and I'm gonna lay them out
appropriately so and then I can use it
as a just another container or component
so I don't and I attribute that I my X
exposing to outside world right so
things like info label like words my
text for for minimum for maximum or
current right so that it's all
dynamically binded through my outside
world and which is here I can see this
is
again this is my slider controls so
instead of slider Australia control now
that I provide minimum value maximum
value slider value and so forth so I can
build this with components to kind of
spice it up my visualizations so I can
get take a stock component like slider I
can I wrap it into something nicer right
so so that's one aspect of it let's go
back here
this is probably not in the right order
here so I was talking about the enamel
and autumn so the idea is that you write
your enamel a declare your code and then
somehow you need to bind it with your
model so in the middle between your
enamel and your cold your model stands
the atom you actually Marvel can extends
the atom or you can have an atom that
you know changes in atom will modify
your model and it can go back and forth
and there is a specific syntax that the
normal use which I'll show you in a file
so basically if you do assignment that
means just a simple assignment you can
assign the value to your maybe label to
your text to your label
now this it's like a resurrection to the
right so that changes in your UI let's
see in your slider the value of slightly
changes and then it sends it to your
model the other way around
you can do it which is you can update
maybe some thread updates your model and
then it updates UI so now you attribute
on your UI so this way it goes from
right to left so that flows changes from
right to left and then bi-directional
update so that means whatever I change
so basic it's both to those two together
on this so this one basically changes in
one changes another one other one
changes this one so they both back and
go back and forth and there is also
double colon like this that you can
actually perform some action so maybe
there's some additional pop up you wanna
when you click on something and so it's
so this is very kind of interesting the
way that it's designed to allows you to
this provide that flow this is
interesting so and I have it here so now
when you download enamel from their
website isn't that's actually it's in
included in the tutorial it's this this
is your life and ammo editor that if you
want to kind of build your own quickly
markup your own
you eyes in a number you can use that
and it live meanings if I write
something here just about evaluates and
tries to just post my class a second so
let's say I put label
I should text
see you have a label here yeah so you
can click Li quickly build some mock up
your your UI with this editor you know
another label
yeah so we have it to label snow and so
forth so you can put your own components
you can test out the components that are
with enamel even yourself your own
components here you can maybe write some
model just hooks it up makes a little
bit more difficult
so this is very tool it's included in
the tutorial it's basically the same yes
I charmed yeah no no no so this is what
I mentioned before so and I won't
because has that anomaly extension it's
really not recognizable by anything
right but things like pycharm
or some other it allows you to add so in
in what I did in this pycharm I just
screed another fire mode called data
normal and then I just enter there and I
just went and add some syntax into it so
colors is there the color syntax against
death there's another two blank text
everybody is just sublime text and now
actually has only one AMA website you
can download the sublime text color mode
so you can drop it to your sublime text
library so automatically colors nicely
or your fire but that's about it
I it still doesn't and let's I cannot
put the breakpoint yet in a normal fire
I have to actually import PDB and set
the trace in order to kind of get into
that I can do that because it compiles
into a Python code but and editors don't
understand that yet so this one things
are a big ask of I'm gonna mention that
at the end that one of the big asks to
for the community or for the users too
if you want to make it this more usable
and reach more audience you actually
need to better support in ideas like
pycharm or stuff like that so you can
actually integrate it nicely instead of
just tweaking yourself
I mean sublime text has it but it still
doesn't understand this is the the
Python so there's no
extent you know the start you know
completed you know code competition this
doesn't understand that I push button
that and it will doesn't know what's
going on and like in Python I can do
date/time date dark and I can see what
member so that data so this still it's
missing it's kind of annoying but we
need more support more more community
behind it when people start using it
more than I'm sure either somebody's
gonna come up or I was thinking of doing
this for pi day then I switched to
PyCharm I did it in pycharm but I'm new
to it I just did the color highlighting
I didn't do any syntax that probably
have to go deeper within the code itself
to do it because in three parts the fire
or understand what's there and stuff
like that but this editor the only
drawback to this editor is a scintilla
cutest and teleport for the editing for
the text editor so this doesn't really
include Aaron or Y and account that does
not really include that so you probably
unfortunately we won't be able to run it
this example even if you download my
code unless you get somehow the cutest
Zilla from somewhere or our build it
yourself actually building is very easy
just download it and takes five minutes
because once you download and I can type
provide everything you need to compile
the Q T so you have a headers and and
you have a libraries and Q makes you
just like you make make and install and
here we go so it takes a few minutes
really to build it and then you can use
this life editor which is great because
I can really show you something very
cool so for instance I can go and go to
tutorial a normal tutorial and I can go
to maybe layouts
which is
that's this guy
this may be just too much something
simpler for Manama let's get that fun so
basically I probably just can take this
just see I just
just needed content
I'm just copying face here
and I hope this works it didn't work
because this oh here you go
so here we have a couple of examples so
basically you can get that right into
the life editor and kind of play with it
right away and it's all life so she
changes here so it's also this is enamel
so you know again let's me recap this it
has great features a lot of widgets a
lot of controls it's easy to use dynamic
binding with with your model so I
recommend if you want to quickly create
some nice UI you want to grab that and
this life editor again it's it's great
for marking up here your UI is quickly
you need to squeeze in tailor package
and but that's pretty much it nice thing
about UI and an hour the the feature the
probably like the best is this docking
system so it uses this docking pain in
packing area and dark items that you can
put your controls in it and then you can
move them around
it's like Visual Studio C++ and other
stuff that contains the same
visualization I mean the elements so you
can and there's layout first of all you
mentioned the layer layouts
automatically are done for you or you
can apply the constraints using the V
box or H box a combination both to so
you can lay them in the horizontal
vertical where you're just kind of map
you like them together so for instance
this one here like I have let's run some
example
for that so something called I have this
monthly docs example and let me just run
this quickly so I'm gonna comment this
out and I'm gonna run this guy
it's right here alright so here this is
some sort of vtk are mean matplotlib
visualization of some random data but as
you notice i have actually ducking yeah
so i can actually have my attacking
components so i can lay them out have
multiple ones here have a one control
one maybe something else so it's it's
really really interesting and very nice
if you want to create some rich
visualization with the dockings because
you can put them together you have a
controls on one side and and some UI
visualization windows in another area so
so the docking it's really powerful and
it's really nice works very well now
i'll go back to the other example I had
with VPK if you remember
that one has actually more oh no this
one is actually very simple one this one
has only two and you can kind of put in
different way out there here let me run
the one that they run it before
kind of our upper windows
yeah so this one for instance uses the
three windows three docking areas here
all right conduct them
like this likes maybe too much and then
no I because of the resolution so this
is my controller here I can maybe put it
here and somewhere hide it so something
so anyway so what I'm trying to say is
here is that with this backing layouts
it really makes it brings your
visualization to life because you can
put several windows several views on the
same visualization in different places
very easily with just dark control or
dock items and then you just can link
them together in your code and and it
makes it much more richer and nicer
visualizations so that's that's your
docking yeah yeah so it's very simple
easy to be split layout so you have a
visual
vertical split between dark items on the
top and there's a another horizontal
split on them at the bottom so you have
one on the top two on the bottom
horizontal vertical vertical and
horizontal horizontal then you can put
them all together the way you want and
the users can actually move them around
there is the ability to save this as
well so that's that's pretty cool
another very important feature is to do
include dynamic components I'm going to
show this in a second although this is
what I was showing you before that multi
window examples again through different
visualizations with the different places
control but controller so this is like a
typical occation if you in the business
you want to do some UI for the user you
want to make sure that you put this
visualization in in those nice layout
and you've given some control so they
can run it and we can maybe visualize it
slice it and dice it and so forth and
this is again how I bootstrap it so this
is something I was talking about before
a few times lets me rehash it again so
there is a command called and I'm around
so you can run and I'm around you and
I'm of hire that it assumes you have
this main in it so
for instance this life editor
here it has it has to have a mane and in
order to in order to be able to run with
n I'm around right so you have that and
or you can boots up in the code I was
showing this again it just import QT
application and an ammo and then from an
ammo with the normal imports in the
context you use import main or something
else doesn't have to be made and it
could be anything the nice thing about
the bootstrapping this way it's actually
we can pass the arguments in to your
enamel file so for instance I can pass
in this case I have an attribute defined
in my main it called custom title and
I'm passing this as a custom titles I
can pass the arguments so if I would
create like a UI GUI UI for the users I
probably would have a Python fire that
bootstraps this with me and maybe they
can pass some arguments on the command
line and stuff like that so this is this
is a bit better I think so that's one
thing all right before I go to more into
maybe how to now hook this into the QT
send any questions on an enamel I mean
it's really easy you can get your
examples running through it's it's a
declarative language all the components
altogether so let me move to how do i
hook this into the QT I mean VT k so v
TK it's like I said it's very powerful
visualization language and it's you
probably don't see much of talks out
there about it unlike like matplotlib or
pandas it's open-source as well
everybody can use it it's a little bit
harder to use it's harder to understand
maybe but it offers much more powerful
visualization capabilities than anything
out there I think in open source and
there is a simple pipeline that you
create
decaying oh this is like I'll just try
to show you the 50 class in this is so
huge there's like hundreds of classes
very overwhelming but at the end
everything kind of comes back to the
very simple pipeline you input your data
then run it through the data mapper then
you do some data processing maybe
filtering scaling some transformation
then you create an actors there is a
notion of an actor so each element is an
actor could be alive could be some it
could be a bounding box could be a
surface that's an actor and then for
instance have an outline actor right
here's an actor which is data actor and
then I stick at this new render I can
optionally allow me to add camera and
action so the different type of
interactions but basically that's it so
this is your pipeline and anywhere in
that pipeline we can actually the
pipeline the data flows through the
pipeline
every time you render the renders of the
pipeline so you can actually hook
yourself into the pipeline maybe in a
filter level scalar or some
transformation level to change that
through your UI and then rerender it so
then therefore you have those
interactivity here so let me run some
code for this
so for instance the good one is maybe I
should run different one this is extract
so I get the cementery extraction here
and going on around this
so this what a simple visualization and
again I'm kind of hooking myself here
into the to the pipe reservation
pipelines so my settings maybe I want to
change the radius or shrink factor of
these little cubes here
so I can make them bigger you can make
them smaller if you can see that so
again the whole idea of this talk is to
how to build this bizarre such
interactively it's will be if I don't
have this interaction then I will have
to maybe go to my code change it my hand
around it again and see how this looks
go again change it my hand and that's
kind of tedious obviously it's or maybe
I should have to write another I don't
want to write like a dedicated
application for it I mean it's just a
simple visualization write some data
said so and novel actually allows me to
do it very quickly it allows me to show
you the code just hook myself into this
visualization pipeline and just quickly
modify it so this is this is just an
example but can think of anything else
here I have may be additional radius of
this spheres that intersect
yeah and it's it's really simple to use
very fast it's it's very cool and the
code sign again I'm thinking is this I'm
tacking yeah so let me see so what's the
code behind it so again I don't know if
you can see very well but I'm using the
dark items here but what I'm trying to
say is this is my PT key canvas this is
the guy that the renders this geometry
and and I'm declare here there's a
pop-up that you saw that that when I
popped it up I had a couple of things in
it label this is my sliders that I was
the shrink fact that I was modifying
right so you can see here I was using
this
syntax which is bi-directional
connection but I don't have to actually
do that I could say something like this
I could actually have a different syntax
here I could say this just to give you
an example and then but that's just what
mod that comes what comes in but then I
need to send it out so then I say value
here and then in action I say you know
this guy
so that would be very much the same now
notice there's something called
non-locals here so the nice things about
enamel has a something called dynamic
scoping so meaning that I actually
declared this controller here somewhere
right in that guy 10 but then I don't
really need to pass it around and I can
declare this a bit earlier at some point
somewhere in my enamel file when I'm
building in R and then I don't have to
really pass it to this pop-up view the
pop-up view that pops up when I press
this button right so here I went I
button when I press that button and just
pop up this config pop up that says show
and I don't pass anything else here but
through this non-locals dynamic scoping
I can actually get to that controller so
I don't have to really pass this around
so it's very nice feature of enamel this
dynamic scoping so I can get to that and
then this control here we have this
render controller into which I'm popping
up this view this canvas view this vtk
Converse view and that comes from
extract model just want to show you how
this donut in that model extract model
yeah so this extract model now I think
that I was building to control this
visualization contains a couple of
attributes or properties one of them is
the shrink factor and I declare this to
be float so again the atom 1/2 you have
to kind of pre declare this guys this
yield properties attributes ahead of
time so he knows how to optimize the
compile it into your you know into the
atom object and there is something
called very Jen so so basically usually
you know what you want your strength you
want to float you want you know some
other stuff but sometimes you don't like
just like a generic object I don't know
what it is
so it's interesting because they there's
the two things you can do that one thing
is you can do the value value is very
generic so this data actor is obviously
some sort of vtk object with the key
class I don't even know
I mean I know but usually may you not
know what it is so you just say
generically value and this Optima item
at will automatically find it for you
what it is and bind it and makes it work
or you can have this another call if you
actually know what it is let's say you
exactly know where this is a vtk pulley
mapper class you can say typed vtk poem
upper class so this exact mine
he knows what what to resolve it right
away the bottom line is that we declared
those variables here and I'm building my
model here so this is like a stack
example yeah there's nothing really into
it there's a visualization pipeline
going on and
what's more important is this class here
this rendered view controller so this is
something that I came up with this you
can look to the code I'm not gonna go to
small details but this allows me to kind
of create that renderer and basically
this one this guy here is it's part of
the examples you can find it and basic
allowance they're like maybe different
movement of joystick or Mouse and stuff
like that so this is very generic the
idea here is that and this baby maybe
it's a duplication I just did it to kind
of explain it but as you see I do it I
did it almost twice
so like the shrink factor is in both
places but what's here is that how does
animal know so how does my UI knows that
I was chair I was changing I was
changing my radius oh my my shrink
factor and actually something happened
right so the nice thing about the an
hour and the atom is that it knows that
when members its members are modified so
you can catch that you can catch that in
action so basically here do it two ways
you can do something like underscore
observe shrink factor so underscore
observed so when they when the compiler
compiles it it knows that underscore
observe and anything after that it's the
property so it's a shrink factor right
so every time I'm changing the shrink
factor from my your I this gonna happen
this this this code is gonna execute so
now I'm capturing this and I said oh my
value changed so let me and obviously
when I build the geometry you know I
kind of exposed certain components to it
like geometry like outline like filter
and once I had that exposed then I can
also go and say oh now my shrink factor
change let me just modify that geometry
with that new value and just call render
and that's it so I have my component I
have my model that exposes these members
the when they get modified they just
modify the underlying geometry or
collar or scale or whatever you want and
you just rerender so therefore you have
that dynamic visualization so if you run
another example maybe this is okay let
me just go to this because I know how
much time we have okay we still have
some time okay so so again we can hook
you ourselves to any point in the data
pipeline visualization in order to
modify it right and you can do again you
can do slicing and dicing I'm gonna run
this demo in the end you can change the
scaling resolution all this is from UI
to the atom model into the visualization
and this whole bunch of visiting here
for instance let me run this vtk sample
grid view enamel so so there is an
example in vtk you just can run it
directly and nice thing about this is
that because vtk cameras you provide the
renderer and most of the examples in vtk
when you download it they just create
the renderer so they create all this
actors with that have all these
different transformation and data maps
at the end they create the actors they
stick the renders all you have to do is
just get that render and stick it to the
canvas so I can run this example I
forgot what was some per good view okay
and so this one is this the nice thing
about it is I said okay so it's obvious
you can run this assess but it's not
really interactive right it's it's just
let me just sound it again
with salaries under their own
I hope this gonna run because I'm not
sure if I have a day time right oh you
know I don't have a data in the right
place that's okay let me run that's how
they happen we can run the other one
basically surface view or now let's try
this with the key surface Europe I hope
that I have to restart this
well the other way around because I
guess the data was in the wrong place so
here this another example of a stock and
I mean cure vtk applications and it's
very static but it's really it can very
quickly I can hook it up to it and just
change maybe scaling and change some
resolution of the of the data again it's
the same same idea you're binding your
own you're binding your your UI into the
model that controls the geometry or
visualization flow so and you don't have
to really worry about much because
everything is wired dynamically on the
under the under the hood so you have to
just worry about modifying the
components let's run another one and we
run this one let's run this let's run
this one this is nice one so this one is
in a different folder this is one is in
vtk lip folder and you run this with
leaky surface them around so this one
that's really nice because I hope to
explore this little bit farther into a
little bit bigger visualization in here
we have some sort of surfaces and we try
to hook up yourself is this all the same
thing so I'll show you the code in a
moment but I've hooked up a little bit
more components to it so things like
maybe changing the color month you know
everything is so basically what I do is
I have a list of color maps and I pick
her up one and I stick it into the
pipeline at certain level certain point
in the pipeline I've manipulated the the
color map and then nice thing about this
that I have also the slices so if I want
to slice the data I can maybe run the
slicer here through the data as you see
this long and I can take that data this
is part that is missing in this
visualization I can project that slice
into two dimensional charts so I can
hook here lets him up with lip and eye
every time I slice this I can take that
in fact I do that at work many times we
have a some structured data our term
data volatility surfaces or something
like that and you want to grab that from
the surface and you wanna slice it too
and see what happens at each stage so
therefore then you combine
three-dimensional visualization with the
two-dimensional projection right because
charting it's always better in 2d you
can do some 2d charting in BTK but
that's not going to look good so so this
is again very simple
and yeah I can change maybe back under
the collar you know it's not very nice
so anyway so the this everything here is
interactively controlled through a now
let me move a little bit faster because
we have few more minutes left and I just
want to show you a couple of things so
this is this now matplotlib so there is
a really big interest of Mapetla out
there and in the end most people use it
in notebooks I want to use it in an
interactive visualization so there is a
way to do it there is still some missing
pieces
talk to the authors maybe later but in
the end that's your pipeline so you have
your figure you add the subplot that get
you access then you configure your
access and then you make a color bar or
some lines of thickness all that stuff
and then basically you add your data to
it and just stick it to the figure
canvass the figure compass is stick
actually part of the Imperial canvas
enamel so all you do is just create
those and every almost every example
that is out there like you know you know
map tulip website you can modify very
easily to run through this examples with
enamel so for instance let me just so
you understand that I mean most of
people are familiar with with matplotlib
so this is kind of simple simplify
pipeline but that's what we try to do
here again you can MPL canvas because
with corona' mo but you can up you know
extend it as as you did with VTA with
something else you can have like AI in
this examples I have something called it
key and peele container basically what
it does it just puts a couple of things
together for me so every time I don't
have to just redo it so just stick it in
the visualization all the time and let
me run through a couple of
visualizations here so let me run
through this grid data then one
I just closed all this
so
if you run this on your own I have this
employed demo round that py that I just
commit out a couple of examples here so
basically we have to do is just comment
out and run the one that you want
so we're only gonna run and we're going
to encrypt it oh no this one actually is
in a different place this way and I have
two of them let me run this guy I guess
we can understand
okay so again this is your mat plot lab
embedded in animal and that hook i hook
up some UI components to it to
manipulate this this is the stock
example you can find it on the website
and just kind of manipulate the one
thing I've done it here is maybe let's
say I want to change the color map
everybody hates this rainbow column up
so well this one maybe like pink yeah
anyway so I actually this all these
column maps comes with MATLAB I just
have a little utility some weather that
extracts all this from it and then just
sticks it into the into the normal
components and then you just can get it
and so it's just example of how easy
this can be right and here I have some
configuration as well maybe I want to
this is again there was a static example
with there was a certain number of
counters some certain color mob what I
did is just okay let me just make it a
little bit more interactive so I wanted
to quickly change the color mouse and I
want to maybe change number of counters
right so you know so I can do that as
well and it's all it is is basically
what I do is what's showing the code in
a second is I hook again my properties
of my model into the UI and then where
every time you change the UI then I go
into that pipeline that you saw and I
modify the some properties of the figure
or of access and I just redraw the only
thing you have to do is just clear it
every time otherwise you will compound
the visualization on top of it so here
it's basically the cold I don't know if
you can see but basically it's again a
simple main back since the window and
there's a whole bunch of labels and this
is my object combos
of them this is the config pop-up that I
pop it up in order to get your slices
and then it's a color map here I get my
color maps and then obviously this is
just the UI this is your declaration if
you are you notice also there's a lot of
this examples I actually mix and match
and there's another proof of this that
this is an ammo can be a great and it's
like Python so I just basically sticker
my my Python code in it
write the class great more right now the
only disadvantage of this using an
enamel is that you have really less
control of of debugging right of or
maybe the editor doesn't support all the
features right so for instance if you if
I wanna I'm gonna show you in a second
but let's say I have this another
keyword so I showed you this one way to
notify the member how does in an ammo
when it's notified through your I
another one is to this cue observe so
and here I can actually stick together
several one so now we're counters color
map number of points so basically what I
do is every time one of this attributes
gets notified this function gets rerun
but basically what it does it's
basically rip lots the data right so in
I'm using this deferred code this is
very important if you are actually want
to use the real-time visualization in
real time because you want to make sure
that every time the thread updates your
mother the mother then has to obviously
update your UI you want to do it on the
main UI thread so that deferred call
allows you to do so and this is my draw
labels some redrawing the labels and I'm
here redrawing my data so this is my
data and then basically I just rerun the
data with number of points and that's it
and I just redraw it so now every time I
change the UI this code executes redraws
the data
and then you have this dynamic
visualization we run another example let
me run I don't know what was this one
again all this examples are there
they're all working except you might
have to modify a little bit the location
of the icons yeah this is actually the
same thing except this one
oh so this one has no this actually
doesn't work this one is just same thing
the other one is one has all this
dynamic so this one was just example of
having this very topic visualization and
the other one is just how do I spice it
up by modifying things right let me run
another one how about something that has
like a real-time update so
so this again example from the from the
website the scatterplot
and again I want to make this a little
bit more dynamic by hooking up my UI
into the pipeline of this drawing so
first of all I can refresh this easily
right so this is pretty good performance
then we have I can change my titles
alright and then I can change my data
points and then maybe change the radius
so again it's how dynamically I can you
know hook my UI through a novel with the
with underlying and the code itself is
very simple
and now there's another one I have here
which is very similar but what's nice
about it is this has some sort of I
guess I guess we run over time sorry let
me just learn this one what the heck
this one has you have to look to the
examples this one has the this one has a
automatic threading so this is almost
like your like your dynamic animation
right so start/stop anyway it's time to
finish so conclusion so I hope I showed
you how to easily manipulate the your
visualization with enamel by hooking up
certain components and the future like I
was talking to someone here more QT
widgets support maybe
pycharm other IDE support extend maybe
within the back ends that's it thank you